so i got out of a
about a 15-month relationship with a
single mommy over the weekend
and it was one of the most bizarre
experiences i've ever had because i've
never sat down and had a conversation
with someone and then and you know say
this is what i want this is what i want
to do and this is it there was no
conversation no really argument no
discussion to have
but she literally didn't let me break up
with her it was absolutely bizarre like
what i'm not letting you go or like what
was she saying
she said that it was not a joint
decision it had to be a joint decision
that breaking up was not interesting
[Laughter]
oh my god the audacity eh it's got to be
a joint decision it has to be a joint
decision i would say okay
how did you handle that
um i played the part for the remainder
of the weekend because i was
kind of the the saving grace with this
one was that it was two and a half hours
relationship like two and a half hours
away so whenever you want to break up
with her what did she do wrong
you know honestly it was you know
and i want to say to um to john earlier
he was saying you know the six month
thing take it longer
take it longer because she played the
part she did a great job she even with
two kids she showed me you know she was
willing to you know commit and do the
things i asked her to do stay in my
frame and all these things
but it was a very slow gradual and i
felt like the analogy i was making to
some of my friends was
i felt like the frog in the pot that was
slowly raising up to boiling temperature
yeah so you know it was
it was very slow and gradual and i think
she knew what she was doing in that
regard so
that that being said yeah it was just
too much with the uh the kids and the
the soccer practice and the karate and
this and that and going
all that stuff too
absolutely yep did you did you get
yourself in a position where you've got
um like
all the responsibility of a parent with
none of the authority or did you have
some authority
and that was a conversation actually um
i had with her and i said you know that
was my main concern i said i don't want
to be in that scenario where i'm
responsible with no authority and she
said to me that she gave him
i will give you as much authority as i
can you know if you want to discipline
them i'm not going to say anything to
you unless it's something that is
absolutely ridiculous and we can have a
conversation about it so
you know she in that regard did kind of
do those things but no it just it can't
work out all right
never doing a single mom again
all right well that's uh there you go
guys there's another share there's
another experience uh share for you guys
do you have a question too or
i do actually on the uh the spinning
plates thing so i have never done that
i'm not very experienced in it so other
than you know obviously your book and
those kinds of information i've seen
some stuff with rolo and whatnot but
what's a good kind of beginner's guide
to start and get into spinning plates
and kind of practice that
well i mean
you should know that it's effective um
because it's basically a tool that we
took from women's tool chest you know
women are natural plate spinners because
they're hypergamous right so they're
always looking for the best deal they
can get so
i mean if you see a girl in a dating app
you know on tinder or bumbler or
whatever she's likely not single she's
likely seeing another guy or several
other guys and she's weighing out some
options
right so all you're really doing is
you're taking a tool from their tool
chest and being like all right you know
that's a good idea you know i like that
one um and then you just do it you just
you just
start dating and you let the cream rise
to the top and there's gonna be some
women like you know it's like the whole
plate spinning thing and i know rollo's
got a bunch of blogs on it but it's like
you know you put a plate on you start to
spin it it just kind of sits there and
it just goes
after a while eventually
a few of them are going to fall off
after a while you know some of them are
just going to have some good momentum
and all you do is throw a few inputs in
and they just keep going and that's all
that it really is right i mean just kind
of go about your life you chase
excellence you know you're going to date
a few women and you're doing it so that
you can weigh out options a man with
options has a
is in a very very good position right
especially if they're in a if if they're
out there looking for women because
there's a lot of guys that still want to
have kids or they want a girlfriend you
know sort of thing
that's a way to like kind of
filter through you know the wheat to get
the chaff sort of thing right
so it's it's um you know you got to
separate you know the riff from the
wrath a guy once said to me um you know
you're going to have to dig through a
lot of dirt to find gold and that's all
that plate spinning can really be
distilled down to there's no real
handbook that i've seen i mean i'll i'll
probably
i don't maybe i'll put a chapter in my
book on it from my own experience and
views and uh some of my uh bits and
pieces of advice on it but
it should be natural and comfortable
right like i don't like that okay do a
and then b and then c and then d it's
like just do your thing date a bunch of
women um when you're when you're early
on you know you don't see them more than
once a week like you know
i don't know do you have kids are you
divorced like what's your story right
now
uh no kids no divorce no nothing just
okay so basically between your extra
extracurriculars if you're playing
hockey with friends or you you know hang
out and play poker from time to time on
certain nights you've got a lot of open
nights right absolutely so it's like
okay i'm gonna do dates on tuesdays and
thursdays and saturdays or something
like that and it's like you know the
women that you start to spend more time
with that you're starting to dig their
vibe on then you can spend time with
them more on the weekend but the newer
ones should be relegated you know
basically to the weekdays right
you know it's a quick low time
commitment if it's a first-time date
it's like an hour you have a coffee or a
drink you go for a stroll you just kind
of check them out you know make sure
that you dig her vibe shoot the exhaust
sort of things and then you kind of
escalate from there and you take them
you know take them through the second
date and the third date and all that
it's like you know you're getting it in
intimacy you're learning more about what
they're doing you know with their lives
you're trying to figure out you know is
this somebody that i want to spend more
time with you know maybe not you know
maybe they're crazy you want to keep
them at arm's length because
you know cuckoo for cocoa puffs you know
it's it's it's really just a
tool that you use to kind of assess what
they're really made of that's all it
really is okay gotcha and then a similar
idea for like a an entrepreneur or
whatever higher slow fire fast kind of
thing higher slow fire fastest you know
it's the same thing with women same
thing with employees same thing with
business partners vendors it's a very
good rule in life you know that's why i
put that in a chapter in my book hire
slow fire fast you know take your time
to see what somebody's made out of and
when they show you what they're made out
of you know who they who they really are
that's what you got man you just get rid
of that it's like see you later we're
done one final thing if i can um so i've
got some you know obviously
more disposable income now that i don't
have this uh
uh
looking at joining your community and i
wanted to have a just a quick question
for you
interested in doing that and
do you foresee increasing the yearly
price for the regular non-business
membership anytime between now and say
tax season next year or um yeah i'm
always increasing the prices to my
community over time but it it just
improves the quality of the dialogue and
the conversations and the people in
there um but i mean you're always
grandfathered in whatever the entry
point is i mean i've got some ogs in
there from like the early years that are
paying you know next to nothing and
they're not going anywhere but um yeah
the prices always go up over time gotcha
excellent thank you so much
you